cae una de las culturas corporativas
mejor organizadas del mundo y empieza a
escribirse otro capítulo en la Nueva Era
de Twitter bajo la batuta de elon musk
si está en una oficina o de camino a una
oficina regrese a casa esta frase
enviada a sus empleados fue el antes a
la de los cambios y recortes que lleva a
cabo su nuevo y multimillonario dueño
desde su adquisición la orden estaba
dada encontrar hasta mil millones de
dólares en ahorros anuales un mandato
que se tradujo en despidos masivos las
oficinas de la compañía a nivel mundial
amanecieron cerradas este viernes y los
despidos fueron anunciados por
comunicación interna de la empresa las
reacciones de los empleados no se
hicieron esperar detenidos ante la
angustia de un futuro incierto al
conocer que no podían acceder a los
sistemas de la empresa bueno Esto no
parece prometedor no puedo iniciar
sesión en los correos electrónicos me
desperté con la triste noticia de que ya
no soy un tweet Me encantó cada momento
trabajando en el equipo global Twitter
comments colaborando y aprendiendo de un
grupo ex mi canal de personas talentosas
a pesar de la incertidumbre interna que
vive la compañía del Pájaro Azul El
Magnate sudafricano ve otras causas en
la caída que experimenta la empresa
Twitter ha tenido una caída masiva en
los ingresos debido a que los grupos de
activistas presionan a los anunciantes
Aunque nada ha cambiado con la
moderación de contenido e hicimos todo
lo posible para calmar a los activistas
extremadamente desordenado están
tratando de destruir la libertad de
expresión en Estados Unidos La ola de
despidos comenzó la semana pasada con la
junta central a lo que se sumaron las
renuncias de otros altos cargos
empleados ya han presentado una demanda
colectiva contra la empresa denunciando
que el preaviso de 60 días para un
despido masivo no fue respetada lo que
violaría la ley laboral Federal